hello everyone and welcome to a really
nice game uh between ray robson and ho
yifan it's from the 2004 under 10 world
championship and um today's hu yi funds
a 27th birthday so i decided to show a
nice game
and we haven't heard uh from her for a
while he is the
she's the highest rated uh uh women
chess player in the world uh from active
players of course judith polgar
uh still holds the highest rated uh
woman player ever
and uh she's been away from the chess
world for quite some time
and she assumed the position i think um
last year maybe even this year as the
youngest ever professor
uh in shenzhen in china uh in the
shenzhen university
uh so it would seem that she's uh
uh succeeding in other aspects of life
as well
uh but um this is quite a game and i'm
sure you're gonna enjoy it you all know
ray robson he
i think we even mentioned him yesterday
uh he is the
uh current seventh uh number seven in
the usa
uh behind the names like fabiana caruana
wesley so linear dominguez hi karna
kumara jeffresh young and sam shankland
uh and even though he is i think some
maybe even 20 points higher rated than
haifa now who even
has the highest ever peak rating
higher than robson by a few points so
they were
very close then they are very close now
so let's check out the game and then
we're gonna
discuss a little bit about this more so
robson with the white pieces
opens with e4 and ethan as she is a very
fighting uh
player herself goes c5 the sicilian
defense is on the board we have knight
f3
d6 and d4 now we have capture sculptures
in the now
knight to f6 we have knight c3 and a6 so
the
knight of sicilian is on the board and
uh it's a very
interesting uh thing to keep in mind
while i was analyzing this game i used
every
uh available resource much like i do
when i
analyze games of absolute top grand
masters and
bear in mind that they are nine years
old while playing this game and it's
still
really really awesome so here bishop to
e2 just continuing development this is
all still very
standard theory we have e6 uh
and now uh white castles we have queen
to c7
and here white wants to prevent uh
black's expansion with
five so white plays a4 this is again all
very standard we have b6 preparing to
finca to the light square bishop
and put additional pressure on this e4
pawn with
f4 and now bishop to b7
so now the pawn is under attack you have
to defend it and here
bishop to f3 so this is all very
standard we have knight beat to d7
this knight now wants to come to c5 to
add a third attacker to the e4 pawn
and not a problem king to h1 a nice
prophylactic move you want to get
the king away from this diagonal to
avoid any any future checks and
this is something you uh should almost
always do when playing against
the the the sicilian or such openings as
um
yeah best just try and play against king
to h1
and see what will happen and then you
will realize that a king to h1 is a much
needed move so bishop to e7
uh even continues development and now
the immediate
g4 so it looks a bit dangerous as it
opens up this diagonal but
white is uh nicely defending everything
it says that
this will not be an issue knight to c5
by efa now adding a third attacker to
the e4 pawn
and now queen to e2 adding a third
defender we have h6 now
preventing g5 for the moment you could
play g5 but then h capture just opens up
the h5 for the rook and then with this
pressure along the h file and this
pressure along this diagonal
it would not be a fun time for for the
white king so here bishop to d2
uh connecting rooks a continuing
development and now
g6 by efan and it is uh as of move 14
that the disposition was never
reached again and now white has to
decide what to do here
do you go for some sort of a
breakthrough do you try and uh
bring more uh bring more presence into
the center of the board maybe rook to e1
uh there's the idea of f5 there's the
idea of b4 so
those are the ideas that are uh possible
here
and we're gonna discuss b4 because it's
the the engine stop recommendation but
it's not
it's not something because after the
knight moves we have b5 now
preparing to capture an a6 and bring one
of our knights to b5
and then black would probably capture
his captures and after captures we would
get captured so this is
uh something that that white can look
forward to
uh maybe white can exploit this by going
rook to a7 but it doesn't seem like
like there's all that much here so uh
robson instead goes for
the other idea not b4 but rather he
strikes with f5 as the black king is
still in the center maybe it uh
it does make sense so here we have e5
closing off the e file of course
and now knight back to b3 you you should
always check moves like f captures and
g6 just in case it works for example
captures captures now this comes with
check and after king captures now you
realize that there is really not all
that much for you to do here there's no
way to exploit the open f file the
bishop is
hemmed in with the the g and e pawn but
you could do something like knight here
attack everything and then if something
like
captures captures you get the open e
file as well you might bring this rook
to e1 and you have a lot of
a lot of pressure along these lines and
you've locked the light square bishop
out of the game so although it's not not
great i know some people that that would
go for this
so instead of uh that after e5 we have
just knight back to b3
and now g5 closing off the position uh
not interested in in getting attacked
and now uh yifan wants the castle queen
side
push h5 open up the h file and now use
uh
the rook for the attack so a5 robson
wants to start attacking on the queen
side as
this is where e fun will castle and now
b5 again just closing off um
any any openings of the files we have
knight captures on c5
d captures on c5 and now rook f2 e1
adding yet another defender to the e4
pawn
we have queen side castles and now
bishop to e3
so what do you do here well we just
continue with our plan and our plan is
to open up the h file so here ethan
pushes h5
now of course um the idea is just to
open the h file and hopefully double up
but this also comes as a as a pawn
sacrifice a bishop captures on g5 is
possible
but it's a it's a question whether you
even want to capture this pawn eruption
decided that he will capture this pawn
but this means that the g
file will open up as well so we'll see
if we if he will be able to withstand
this pressure
h captures on g4 we have bishop capture
sanji for
knight captur sanji for queen captures
and f6
now and now with this bishop uh forced
uh to move back
the rook is coming to g8 and then it's
gonna be it's gonna be
uh a very very questionable if white can
uh can hold this with bishop back the e3
but this uh simply doesn't work and it's
a very tricky position there's
there's basically only one move that
wins for sure here for black
so feel free to pause the video and find
this move for yi fun
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations i'm not
going rook d to g8 right away and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
it's uh b4 that b4 is the
move that uh wins in this position and
it's uh
very interesting why uh the problem is
if you go
something like this you attack the queen
the queen simply moves queen to e2
and there doesn't seem to be all that
much you can do if b for now knight d5
and white defense white defends well
the problem with uh white defending the
position after b4 immediately and
this was played in the game is that the
d5 square is off limits to you and this
is very important
the knight is also the defender of the
e4 pawn and opening up this diagonal
would be huge the problem with knights
to d5 is that black would capture with
the rook
and after the rook is accepted bishop
captures here with check
also guards the g8 square and this is
huge white has only one move that to
basically make sense king g1
and then rook to g8 wins the queen and
well
white white just resigns so here after
this uh b4 move robson said okay i can't
play knight to d5 unfortunately i'm
going to go knight to a4
but now comes rook d to g8 and now it's
much different
we have queen to f3 you have to keep an
eye on this pawn because the knight no
longer defends it
and now rook to h4 adding another
attacker here
so here first knights to b6 check king
to b8 and now we have to defend this
pawn the only way to do it is to move
the bishop
so bishop to g1 now the rook and the
queen are defending the e4 pawn
and now comes rook to f4 now we start
harassing the white queen
queen to d3 and now rook to d8 again
you have to keep an eye on the e4 pawn
so the the queen has no more squares we
have knight back to
d5 and here comes c4
uh also possible here was just rook
captures on d5 that that also works but
if i first play c4 checking to see what
uh what white will do here now basically
it's an offer of
of a queen trade and if white goes for
this for example captures captures
uh the the position is lost for for
white for example
knight to the e6 goes after the rook
tries to save the knight
uh there's the very simple rook captures
on e4 and there is not much you can do
you are threatening some very very nasty
discoveries here
and if for example knight captures on d8
uh now
preparing to eliminate the the bishop
that it's
that's ready to give check you just play
rook characters on e1 deliver check from
the bishop
knight has to capture it and now you can
even play d2 and that's just it
next move you're bringing a queen into
the game or rather you will capture on
a1 then bring the queen into the game if
white captures you're gonna bring a
queen into the game this
way it's uh completely lost for black so
instead after this c4 move by iphone
uh we have queen to d2 uh and now comes
the move that could have been played
move prior to this rook captures on d5
we have e captures on d5 and now adding
another attacker to the d-pawn
queen to d7 now the threat is bishop
captures here
so rook 8 to d1 adding another defender
and now comes rook to d4 a beautiful
idea
even sacrificing more material uh to
open up the this diagonal
now the rook has to be captured there's
really not nothing much better
rook bishop captures here was played but
now
queen captures on d5 first and now it
doesn't really matter what you do
uh you are you are getting destroyed
either way in the game king to g1 was
played but now it's actually a forced
checkmate in three so feel free to pause
the video and win the game for yi fun in
three moves uh while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding
h1g2f3 and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
it's actually that queen to h1 check
only move king to f2
now we play queen to g2 check only move
king to e3
and now we finish it with a nice queen
to f3 checkmate
the white king is in check and of course
the bishop and the queen prevent the
king from escaping uh
to any squares that the the black queen
does not cover
also something to to always remember as
if you're trying to
if you're going for a king hunt if
you're trying to checkmate your
opponent's king
it's always good to know that this
pattern here is is basically checkmate
or rather this setup here is checkmate
if
uh these two squares are not available
to the white king
so very very interesting it would be the
same if the queen was here checking the
king and then you would
uh need these two squares to not be
available to the the white
king it works all the way around and uh
regarding the uh the final standings of
this
of this tournament uh yifan actually got
a shared first place the tournament was
won by yu yang yi
uh followed by jill mussar uh huifan and
song raymond
uh those were uh four of them had nine
points uh but
due to better additional criteria yu
yangi yuyungi was
was the winner but still a very very
impressive performance
and also i wanted to mention that uh
yeah yifan did win the the world women's
championship four times but she stopped
competing in women's events um some time
ago
and today to to this date uh her
biggest tournament victory is considered
not actually winning the
the women's world championship but
rather this uh
beal super tournament in 2017
as you can see she won first place ahead
of some incredibly strong grand masters
like etienne bakr and tala hari krishna
ruslan ponomari of peter lecko nico
giorgiades alexander morosevich david
navarra
rafael vagani and no so those are
incredibly incredibly strong players
some rated over over 26 50 some rated
over 2700 so
quite quite quite an achievement so
we'll see if she will return
chess seriously or will she continue her
uh
career as a university professor i know
and i've read for a fact that she will
be playing some tournaments but i don't
know
uh if she will like you know try try and
go all the way but we'll see she's still
very young so
anything can happen i'm very very eager
to see uh
where she goes uh where she goes next uh
so yeah
that's the game i hope you guys enjoyed
it uh really really a nice uh
game and like i said i used all of the
resources i use
the i use when analyzing grand master
games and uh the
this game was played by nine year olds
so it's uh
an incredibly impressive game uh so yeah
uh once again hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank sahib demon uh jim
ivanov oliver
nova and roger stone for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day